Use less than or greater than
for this little brackets thing
to write a true sentence.
So they essentially want us to
say whether 45.675 is greater
than or less than 45.645.
So let's look at each
of these numbers.
I'm just going to write them
on top of each other.
So the first a number is
forty-five and six hundred and
seventy-five thousandths and
the second number is
forty-five and six hundred and
forty-five thousandths.
Now when you look at everything
here, the only
place where these two numbers
are different is in the
hundredths place.
We have 7 hundredths here and
we have 4 hundredths here.
Everything is the same,
so this number
is going to be greater.
This number is a greater than
45.645, or six-hundred and
forty-five thousandths.
Let me write that down
just to make sure we
know what we're doing.
Forty-five and six hundred and
seventy-five thousandths, or
45.675, is definitely greater
than 45.645, or forty-five and
six hundred and forty-five
thousandths.